[Musique]
m ne faites pas développé dans les pays
froids et notre corps est incapable de
résister au froid on meurt et l'afl ce
afin de d'éviter la mort fait et grâce à
la technologie donc fond de teint
naturel l'humain n'est parfait produit
vers l'an dernier un essai maudite hiver
est apparue au québec publié aux
éditions la presse dans lequel le
chroniqueur du quotidien du même nom
alain dubuc des notes toutes les raisons
d'un poème univers à peu près nulle part
sur la paix dans le monde et fait guéri
mais non il ya le québec le canada
fernand le pays qui est le plus
rigoureux beaucoup plus que les pélicans
club et donc il ya un combat à munich et
et dans les camps des gens puisque
d'univers ce qui m'a frappé c'est que
bien sûr qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
aiment les quatre raisons qui m il ya
des de beaucoup de plaisir ce fait
divers mais ce que les gens aimeraient
d'entre ceux qui aiment univers il ya
ceux qui paient les autres aimeraient un
univers qu'ils ressemblent pas tenu
compte aujourd'hui font endurer des
refroidissement éolien qui sont
particulièrement froid aujourd'hui du
côté de red deer on aura moins 35 le
niveau des températures ressenties
refroidissement éolien
jusqu à -36 abang se dégage en après
midi
ce serait donc au coeur de l'hiver en ce
troisième lundi du mois de janvier que
collectivement nous serions les plus
déprimés en fait le blue mandé est
d'abord née d'un coup marketing it ce
moment donné à clairoix nord qui
enseigne la psychologie l'université
cordée par une agence de voyages du
royaume uni en 2005
lagence lui avait demandé d'identifier
la journée de la plus déprimante de
l'année afin de promouvoir ses forfaits
vacances d'hiver on parle encore
d'alphonse à le coller dans les
croyances populaires
julie carignan au québec et psychologues
dans le domaine des organisations quand
même le club phare n'avait pas fait ça
juste sur un coin de table avait utilisé
une formule pseudo scientifiques pour
arriver au troisième lundi de janvier et
s'était basée sur des critères quand
même potentiellement pertinents
comme le nombre de jours avant noël le
taux d'endettement le niveau de
motivation mais tout de même le
plusieurs cris
le concept en expliquant que c'est très
réducteur par rapport aux vrais enjeux
de dépression la réelle des pressions le
sait pas un enjeu d'une journée et
plusieurs aussi grand que le fait
d'avancer le blue mandé pouvait
contribuer à déprimer les gens par
anticipation en annonçaient tous vous
aurez une mauvaise journée lundi
prochain mais je pense qu'on n'a pas
vraiment plus de raisons de crème de
déprimer soudainement lundi
toutefois c'est important d'être
conscient qu'il ya plusieurs éléments
qui peuvent nous saper le moral
actuellement les lundis sont souvent
plus pénible à cause des habitudes
ancrées dès l'enfance au mont on n'avait
pas le goût de retourner à l'école
dans cette période ci de l'année aussi
et particulièrement chez nous on a un
enjeu d'ensoleillement qui aura un
impact réel sur le moral quand il ya
moins d'ensoleillement ça nous a fait
que ça fait plus mal
3 on passe de la magie des fêtes à la
dure réalité du paiement des factures
des fights à peu ça peut que saper le
moral et un dernier élément aussi c'est
con si on s'est donné des résolutions
trop ambitieuse après trois semaines on
commence déjà à casser et on se déçoit
new mind pep
si vous avez oublié où vous ne pouviez
pas programmer des vacances trop bucca
dans le sud en ce mois de janvier
le cinéma pourrait bien être une façon
économique de ramener le soleil dans
votre vie selon un sondage organisé pour
la firme de salles de cinémas cineplex
au canada lorsque les canadiens se
sentent déprimés
plus des trois quarts 78 % d'entre eux
songerait aller voir un film
les ferait rire allée au cinéma est
comme une thérapie en fait parce que la
moitié d'entre nous affirmons qu'après
avoir vu un film nous sentons plus
reposé moins stressé comme si nous
avions pris des vacances le cinéma
serait donc que cette petite évasion qui
nous aiderait à passer cette journée
réputée la plus déprimant de l'année
mais selon les responsables pour que le
remède fonctionne il faut vraiment se
déplacer rester chez soi n'est payant
pour personne pourrait-on dire et
spécialistes de la santé abonde dans le
même sens
le docteur norman universitaire renommé
et auteur spécialisé dans la proche
psychologique dollars estiment qu'une
sortie au cinéma a le même effet sur le
cerveau que des vacances en fait
l'important c'est d'aller dehors
ce qu'il fait soleil durant l'hiver
beaucoup de canadiens maintenant songent
à recourir à ce qu'on appelle la
luminothérapie pour combler la carence
de lumière mais attention pour que cela
fonctionne cela prend au moins des
instruments qui produisent autour de
nous jusqu'à 10000 lumens la lumière
d'une chandelle par exemple un mètre de
nous produire un rubens la dépression
saisonnière qu'avec deux à trois pour
cent des canadiens en majorité les
femmes et après quelques jours seulement
d'utilisation d'une lampe de
luminothérapie
plusieurs utilisateurs voient vraiment
une différence un regain d'énergie
alors ça fonctionne selon des études de
60 à 90% les patients qui ont reçu un
diagnostic de dépression saisonnière qui
vont vraiment avoir des effets positifs
de la luminothérapie président à april
et porte parole du magazine
protégez-vous au québec
elle explique tout ce qu'il faut savoir
sur la luminothérapie un traitement qui
n'est pas bénéfique pour tous et qui
peut coûter cher s'il doit être efficace
points de vigilance parce que si on fait
mal le traitement de luminothérapie
on peut y avoir des effets négatifs en
tout ça peut causer des maux de tête les
problèmes oculaires dans certains cas de
l'insomnie même d'anxiété pour certaines
personnes alors ce qui est conseillé
vraiment c'est de demander conseil à un
professionnel de la santé avant de
commencer officiellement un traitement
soit un médecin qui pourra vous
conseiller
tout d'abord pour vous assurer que c'est
réellement des symptômes qui sont
associés à une dépression saisonnière et
à certaines personnes également qu'ils
ne devraient pas utiliser la
luminothérapie
en tout les personnes diabétiques en
raison de la prévalence de troubles
oculaires pour cette maladie là dans
cette raison l'oeuvre devrait pas
utiliser la luminothérapie
les personnes qui souffrent de
maniaco-dépression également les
personnes qui ont des problèmes
oculaires également les personnes qui
prennent des médicaments
photosensibilisants ne devraient pas
utiliser la luminothérapie comme très un
reportage de radio canada international